Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah. Let's begin.
Okay. So.
We are picking back up again with the conclusion of the Maestro Hawk story,
right.
I kind of wanted to wait until this was done before we wrapped it all up because
it'd been going pretty slow. Right.
And what we kind of found was that over the course of the individual issues,
there wasn't really a whole lot happening.
So I figured we'd go ahead and wait till it ended.
And then just kind of covered all in one go. Right?
So in the last video that we did,
if those of you guys who were playing catch up here,
and the last video that we did,
the Maestro whole had shown up to dystopia only to find out that it was being
ruled by Hercules.
Now this version of Hercules is not the one that we're used to what her Hercules
and Marvel comedies really in recent years,
I would say more so than in the old years,
but in more recent years has largely been depicted as a kind of jovial guy that
the superhero community doesn't really seem to take seriously,
which is ironic because he's wildly powerful,
but in the aftermath of nuclear war and the biochemical weapons that were used
by cipher to kind of eliminate what was left of humanity,
that what we kind of realized when we already knew is that a lot,
a large portion of civilization in the United States had been consolidated in
dystopia, which was formerly New York under the rule of Hercules.
And so for the most part, he doesn't really care about any of his subjects.
And we'll talk about that here in a minute. Instead when he encounters Maestro,
he's just like, he's excited to see it and he's happy to see him.
And then he'd basically the reason for this is because Hercules just misses
fighting people. And so literally a fight breaks out between these two. Now,
one thing to understand about Maestro Hawk,
and this is one of the big differences.
And one of the reasons why when you consider all the different variations of the
incredible health that are out there,
that Maestro is actually one of the weakest is because of the fact that Maestro
does not have the ability to get infinitely strong.
It's one of these things where Marvel kind of created an artificial cutoff that,
you know,
the strength of the level of strength he has now that's as strong as he will
ever be, but you'll never really be stronger than this. I mean, I guess,
you know, his exposure to radiation kind of enhances his strength,
but he doesn't really have the traditional incredible Hulk ability,
which is to become stronger, the angrier he gets instead, you know,
because of the fact that he seems a lot more cunning because he doesn't really
allow himself to be subjected to his own wrath and become almost animalistic in
nature that his intelligence is essentially his weakness here in some ways.
But the fight between him and Hercules, you know, initially is pretty fast,
right? He's able to put up a pretty decent fight,
but Hercules is able to overcome them quite quickly. And in fact,
humble him into the ground where he falls into a sewer system. Now,
at that point, he's met by a person called, uh,
called the court and somebody called pivots, which is basically just they're,
they're essentially like Rick Jones people, you know, the,
the idea of like this rebel group kind of going on and trying to work against,
uh,
Hercules or the very least trying to make life better for people in dystopia.
But what the, with my show kind of vanishing Hercules just kind of walks away,
right. And just, and just leaves it a day. But when the, when Maestro seeds,
Rick Jones, he greets him as an old friend. He's like,
I haven't seen him in a long time because river,
they were exceedingly good friends. Now,
the funny thing about this is that Rick Jones has all kinds of these different
objects and these different artifacts from superheroes that have long since
passed away. Right? So he's got the belt of the century,
he's got the skeleton of Wolverine, he's got the helmet of Magneto.
He's got all these little things here and there,
but all these little trinkets and so on and so forth that he can use for his own
ends,
or just kind of keep them as trophies and remembrances of heroes who used to be.
But one of the things that happens,
there's this kind of discussion between Rick Jones and my Maestro where Rick
Jones really kind of tells them, like,
it's your job to basically do something to save this right? Because you know,
all the people out there, like they're ordinary people that,
that Hercules doesn't really care about that.
But my show doesn't really care about the ordinary people either.
And the reason behind this is because ordinary people were the ones who killed
the world, right? It was not some great, big,
huge conflict between the superheroes and the supervillains that laid waste to
the planet or anything like that.
It was ordinary people who engage themselves in nuclear war, right.
It was the world's the world leaders and all that kind of stuff.
And it's one of these things where you can kind of extrapolate and draw
conclusions from this, right?
If world leaders had kind of moved in the direction to where they were going to
engage in nuclear war, it's not something that happens overnight.
It's something that takes time to happen.
And if people never did anything to stop that by voting people out or something
like that, then it means the average person was effectively okay with it, right.
Their apathy and their inaction denoted, acceptance of the situation. And so,
because of that, you know, it's kind of a, an assumption on our part. But the,
the important thing here is that the world collapsed because of ordinary people.
And that's why my show hope doesn't really care at least seems like he doesn't
really care.
The funny thing about this is Rick Jones calls his bluff and he's like,
you know,
Betty Ross was one of those ordinary people that you talk about that you don't
really care about. Betty Ross was one of those.
And so were you once upon a time, I don't know what happened to you.
I don't know what led you to lead you down this path.
But the Bruce banner that I remember would have done something about this,
right? He would have toppled on Hercules and tried to make the world better.
The result of this is that banner and really like Maestro really, you know,
kind of give off this indication that they really do intend to fix things.
And this, once they traveled to Alcom max, right,
which is historically this really nefarious company that exists out there,
but studies a lot of my genetics and different things like that.
But my show basically stumbled across this room where there's all these
individual people who are basically being held in these status units.
And so over the course of the next few months,
we don't really know exactly what he's doing essentially a few months just
passes, but then word reaches the ears of Hercules that Maestro Hoke is back.
And he's currently in the town square.
And what he's doing here is he's basically rallying all the people around him to
his side,
to make him the new leader now for a man that has such little faith in the,
in the average person and rightfully so,
it's kind of ironic that he would in turn,
look to them to make him their leader. Now, there is a little, there,
there is something else kind of going on behind the scenes here,
but Hercules basically pops up in front of nowhere.
Now around the time that Hercules shows up here that a lot of people are just
kind of like what in the world, right?
And that's when my show presents his dogs of war, right? These giant, you know,
mechanical dogs, essentially that he got from Outbacks, right. That he got from,
from the different resources and things that they were presumably working on.
And then in term PVL where he's kind of telling people like,
we'll make this world better and we'll branch out into the world and become
better. People are just kinda like, you know, forget that.
So humanity's never really learned anything, right?
Like the collapse of civilization,
hasn't really driven anybody to make the world better. If anything,
they just kind of maintained their own selfish tendencies. And so,
because of that, my show is like, fine. If that's how it's going to be.
And that leads to Hercules showing up in Hercules, you know,
when Maestro sets his dogs of war on, on the, all these individual people,
then Hercules shows up and starts kind of saving them.
But not because he really cares about them. Again,
he doesn't really care about that. Only cares about is just, you know,
spending time with the women in his company and like being drunk and fighting.
That's all he really cares about. Right?
The average person here is irrelevant to him. And that's why, you know,
him doing all this isn't necessarily to save people. It's for him to just get,
to get to Maestro and to fight him. Now,
one of the funny things here is that where my show goes to fight Hercules,
he's like, okay, fine.
Then I'm pulling out all the stops and it's still not enough what Hercules
absolutely thrashes my stroke. Just tears them apart.
One of the funny things he does here is he uses the same move on Maestro that
Hoke used on Hercules and a vendor. Right.
We start like smashing them around and then he makes this comment.
He's like puny banner. I laugh. I chuckled at that.
I thought it was pretty funny. He was a, a good little thing to throw in there.
But the idea is that with, with Maestro going full on against Hercules,
he can't beat him. Right. Because Hercules is simply just too strong. And again,
that's the, the, the inherent weakness of the Maestro.
If we were talking about like, just your standard Savage, Hulk,
this that would be over pretty fast,
because hope would just keep getting angrier and angrier and then ultimately
topple and destroy Hercules. But because of that,
Hercules gets the upper hand and absolutely humbles Maestro and then ultimately
forces my show to give up. Right. He just says like surrender before I kill you.
And when the Maestro surrenders Hercules is like, okay,
now this is kind of ironic here because anybody who read future imperfect,
this is the exact same thing Maestro did to the incredible hole or really
professor hall from the modern era when he was pulled into the future by Rick
Jones and all them using Dr. Doom's time platform,
the exact same thing happened. The two engage in a fight, Maestro,
beat the absolute hell out of professor Holt and then said, submitter,
I'll kill you. And professor hoax submitted.
And so the result of this is that Hercules offers to bring Maestro back to a
Citadel. But ultimately my stress has no, right.
Like I'll return when I feel like I am sufficient enough to return.
And do you honor, right. That kind of a thing. So it was kinda like, well,
we'll pick up this fight a different day when I could actually present you with
a challenge, right. That kind of a thing.
And people who are looking at this are like, this is not going to end well,
and it's not right. It really, really,
really is not because what ends up happening here is that you have Maestro who
shows up seemingly a few years later on the doorstep of Hercules.
And he actually brings a woman with him. Right. And he says,
like I brought company now because of the nature of Hercules,
the entirety of dystopia, things like that,
we know that like she'd being brought here by my show to be given to Hercules,
right. For Hercules to do what he will with her. And that's what happens, right?
The servant of Hercules calls them forward. And then basically, you know,
my shoppers in sin with a woman named Anne Darnell and says, Hey, like, I'm,
I'm here to bring you this person. Or I'm here to bring you this, this,
this gift essentially. And she's anxious to make your acquaintance. Right.
You know, if you, if you know what I mean, and Hercules is like, cool, right?
So he basically takes the girl, you know,
into his quarters and the two of them that he kind of closes everything up and
it looks like it's going to turn into naughty time. Well,
what Anne Darnell ends up doing is transforming into vapor.
And the reason why is because she's part of the UFOs. Now, if those guys,
she don't know who the UFOs are, don't worry. They sock.
They're never really that important in the first place.
But the idea behind the UFOs is that they were basically a handful of crazy guys
who wanted to essentially, uh,
get their powers in the same way the fantastic Ford did, right.
They literally re-engineered everything all the way down to like the original
shovel, the whole nine yards vapor was one of those originally,
or not really one of the original, but vapor was a UFO.
And the idea is that she's an individual that has the ability to quite literally
turn into vapor. Now, the way that Marvel plays,
this is that while she had been around for quite some time, the,
what actually ended up going on here is that in the aftermath of the nuclear
war, that, uh, that MODOK, who we saw at the beginning of the story,
basically advanced idea mechanics had essentially rounded up anybody who had
either already been mutated and survived or anybody who had been mutated by
virtue of the nuclear war. And then basically put them in stasis.
And that's what all those pods were.
They were people who had been rounded up by advanced idea mechanics,
who presumably had some kind of plan for them,
which ultimately ended up going belly up.
But because of the fact that she turns into our scene, she ends up killing,
killing Hercules. Now to give you guys perspective here,
our scene is fatally deadly at 250 parts per million.
Now there's not really a consistent like measurement across the board in terms
of like, you know, all you need is a,
is some RC in the size of a golf ball and that's 250 pounds of 250 parts per
million. But suffice it to say here,
I would wager that like maybe enough within her hand or like her finger would be
250 parts per million. So you amplify that out and you basically say that like,
you know what equates to 110 pounds of, of gas effectively,
like, or a hundred of what equates to a massive, 110 pounds of gas,
like floods into the skies, uh, this guy's lungs, right?
He dies with a quickness. It's almost instantaneous, right?
Like it's just so fast. And then my show comes busting in with a freeze rate,
freezes up freezes vapor, and then kills her, right.
And gives a whole purpose behind this. The whole idea was to take out Hercules,
if he couldn't defeat Hercules with sheer strength,
he would defeat Hercules with intelligence. And that is the benefit of Maestro.
What he lacks in strength. He makes up for it with his brain.
And that's how he was able to take out professor hall. Right.
Because he was able to out-think it, he was stronger than him,
but he was also able to out-think him, like he was wildly capable.
And so because of that using his brain and really just the brain of banner is
way what's going on here.
He basically has the body of Hercules taken away for a funeral. Right.
So they literally burned them out of higher. Right.
Just kind of a symbolic gesture saying like the King of old is now gone.
I'm the one who rules the throne now.
And you kind of have this discussion where like, the citizenry are like, well,
maybe we should have some kind of an election. And he was like, okay,
well I nominate myself. If any of you guys have any beef with this,
then you can take it out with my dogs of war and literally sends us dogs of
warrant to attack everybody again. Right. Kind of solidifying, like,
I'm the one who's running the show here. Now at that point,
you end up having the forces of Rick Jones who show back up again.
When Rick Jones realizes the,
my show is going to take over dystopia that he's not going to save the world.
He's going to conquer, what's left of it and rule it just like Hercules dead.
And so what he ends up doing is giving us followers a weapon that was built by
forge for the purpose of killing a Hawk, right.
To like basically atomize an incredible hole. And so when this weapons used,
of course, Maestro smashes the ground,
the weapon goes flying out of the girls' hands and,
and Hercules pops back up again.
And the reason for this is because Hercules basically establishes that he is
actually dead, but in the, in the realm of the afterlife, right?
Whatever you want to call it for Greek mythology in the underworld that Haiti's
had basically granted him a reprieve that Hades allowed his body to come back or
a lot of spirits to reenter his body, to get vengeance on Maestro.
And then when that's done, presumably he would go back to the underworld again.
Right. He wouldn't really go to Olympus. Not really sure why,
but he would basically just, you know,
go back to the underworld and that would essentially be it, uh,
largely it could be assumed because of the fact that, uh,
Hercules has done some pretty shady things.
Because as far as I'm aware of Hercules being parked,
God means he would go to go to Olympus when he dies. Right.
He wouldn't actually go to the underworld.
We're pretty much everybody else goes when they pass on.
But regardless of how you slice it,
him being back here allows him to absolutely pummel the Maestro.
Not only that he's powered by the power of a,
Haiti's now something to understand here. This is not Hercules as ghost writer.
I want to establish that wide off the bat. He's not ghost Hercules.
It'd be cool if he was, well, maybe he kind of is right,
because here's the thing,
the various hell Lords that are out there can do different things with,
with different characters. Right?
For the most part we've only ever really seen manifesto create ghost writers,
never really seen like hella create a ghost writer or like Hades create a ghost
writer. But presumably they could,
because a ghost writer is just a spirit of vengeance and that's what he calls
himself. Right. He's literally, he's like, I'm just a spirit of vengeance,
right? Like I'm back here to get vengeance on you. And then as soon as I'm done,
I'll kind of go back, right. He's currently on fire.
So I guess by all standards of measurement, he essentially is a ghost writer.
Maybe not by that name, particularly, but I mean, I guess he kind of is right.
He's back for vengeance. He's on fire. He's powered by a devil. So yeah,
I guess it kind of falls in the category. So, okay. Ghost writer,
Hercules is basically what this is,
but again much like we saw in the previous,
the previous iterations of previous battles,
Hercules gets the upper hand on my stroke.
The difference here is that this Ray basically fires out of nowhere and ends up
completely atomizing Hercules. Right? And when that happens,
we find out it was the servant of Hercules who had done it,
that he never liked him, right? That this, this servant of Hercules never,
ever really liked him and took him out and destroyed him.
And so with that being the case, you know,
my show basically arms himself with his weapon and then tells Rick Jones he's
going for them. The problem is that when he gets to where Rick Jones is at,
Rick Jones is gone. Now we know he's still alive.
We know that from like future imperfect, basically taken off,
he's kind of gone further underground.
But ultimately what Rick Jones really says by virtue of a message is like,
you've just, you become just as bad as Hercules was like,
you could have made the place better. You could've made it,
made this Topia better. You could have led these people into a better place.
You, you keep talking about how, how, you know,
humanity is a problem and all that kind of stuff,
but you were an ordinary person. You've just chosen to forget.
You've just chosen to forget everything.
Like you've basically become your father,
this abusive old man who tore up his kid and made him, you know,
turned his life inside now. And you are the result of your abusive father.
You've turned into them. You've turned into that. Your man,
you care nothing about other people. You know, you use them for your own whim.
You're just as terrible as they are.
And so this basically leads to a bomb being detonated inside the facility that
was planted by Rick Jones, which of course does not kill my stroke,
but it is kind of a message saying like, we can get to you if we want to.
And so following that, you know, where the, the statements kind to put out,
like, what do we do next? The response of Maestro is I'm officially the new,
you know, now the new ruler of dystopia, I run this whole place.
It is now completely under me.
And this is basically how the incredible Hulk becomes the Maestro.
Having said all of that, the stories, okay. If I'm a betting, man,
I think the reason why we have this here is because we're going to see some
variation of the Maestro in the Marvel cinematic universe,
because it doesn't really make any sense for Marvel to give us this story.
Right. Nobody was asking for it.
It wasn't as though there was a huge amount of interest in the character of my
stroke. Like there was a story that we recently got the last time we saw him.
I think it was an old man, Logan. Right.
And it was like one of the last story arcs before you got dead, man Logan.
Right. So I think it was the old, uh,
I think it was Jeff Lameer and I think maybe, uh,
Mike Dougan was drawing into the title number off the top of my head. Uh,
but it's, it's been a long time since we got the character of Maestro, right?
So it's not like this is something that everybody was asking for.
If I'm being honest with you guys,
I think that's what Bruce banner saw during the events of the age of old Trump,
he saw himself becoming the mice joke, this twisted dark version of himself. Ah,
that was basically ruling a future with an iron fist after,
after succumbs to nuclear war. I think that's what we ended up.
I think that's what he saw.
And I think that's what we're preparing to see in the Marvel cinematic universe.
We might see that somewhere along the line or maybe something different, right.
But we'll probably end up seeing my stroke.
It would be cool if we saw that with like King,
the conquer being the new villain that like,
we kind of get this trip through time and you end up seeing the Maestro in the
future. Uh, no idea if that's the case,
because I'm trying to figure out why in the world,
we got the story in the first place.
And that's the only real conclusion I can get is that when we saw things like
blade versus Wolverine, stuff like that, that has something to do with the MCU.
Right? So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob port. If you guys enjoy this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible],
[inaudible].